[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de Parlement Hebdo les moments forts à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat avec
vous Alexandre bonjour Katia on
accueille cette semaine Hervé Marcel
vous êtes sénateur des Hauts-de-Seine
président du groupe centriste au Sénat
président de l'UDI bonjour bonjour il y
a beaucoup d'actualités pour vous Hervé
Marcel a commencé par ces trois semaines
d'examen au Sénat mais finalement
nouveau passage en force le budget 2023
était adopté sans vote ce jeudi en
nouvelle lecture à l'Assemblée
les énergies renouvelables au menu des
députés débats électriques sur la
question des éoliennes l'un des fils
rouges du texte
et puis un débat sur l'immigration au
Parlement en attendant le projet de loi
le gouvernement a exposé les grandes
lignes de son futur texte qui prévoit
notamment d'accélérer les procédures
d'expulsion et le gouvernement a donc
utilisé une nouvelle fois le 49-3 pour
passer en force le budget à l'Assemblée
nationale et ce après trois semaines
d'examens de ce projet de loi de finance
au Sénat ou le texte a été remanié en
profondeur alors retour sur les apports
du Sénat au budget 2023 avec Fabien
reker et Flora sauvage
l'exécutif dégaine un nouveau 49-3 sur
le budget à l'Assemblée c'est la
huitième fois de cette mandature que le
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
reste à savoir ce qu'il gardera des
modifications du Sénat mardi au bout de
trois semaines de discussion et un
record de plus de 2500 amendements la
chambre haute a adopté un budget 2023
largement remanié avec un mot d'ordre
défendre les moyens des collectivités
locales face à la crise exemple avec la
CVAE cette taxe sur la valeur ajoutée
des entreprises qui bénéficient aux
collectivités et que le gouvernement
veut supprimer une suppression rejetée
par le Sénat il reste je le disais de
grands sujets la suppression de la CVAE
que vous avez souhaité supprimer et là
je le dis d'emblée je l'ai dit après le
vote nous proposerons à l'Assemblée
nationale de rétablir la suppression de
la c.v.e mais j'ai bien retenu de nos
échanges que nous pouvions aller plus
loin être plus clair sur les modalités
de compensation pour les collectivités
territoriales pour défendre les
collectivités le Sénat adressé plusieurs
ligne rouge comme sur le filet de
sécurité qui doit aider face à
l'augmentation de leur facture
énergétique les sénateurs ont assoupli
les critères pour que toutes les
communes puissent en bénéficier ils ont
aussi supprimé le pacte de confiance du
gouvernement qui obligeait les
collectivités à contenir la hausse de
leurs dépenses sous peine de sanctions
inacceptables pour les sénateurs qui
redoutent désormais que le gouvernement
supprime leur modification
ma crainte aujourd'hui c'est que ce soit
peut-être un signe supplémentaire
finalement de cette fatigue démocratique
de cette crise institutionnelle le
gouvernement ne peut pas se permettre de
balayer trop rapidement et d'un revers
de main les apports des réflexions et
des propositions du Sénat il faut
vraiment que le gouvernement entendent
la voix des territoires le texte doit
revenir en seconde lecture au Sénat
jeudi mais face au blocage entre la
chambre haute et l'exécutif les
sénateurs pourraient décider de ne même
pas discuter une dernière fois le budget
en rejetant l'ensemble le projet de loi
de finances avant même un nouvel examen
3 dégainé par Elizabeth borne et ce que
le gouvernement banalise ce passage en
force face au Parlement
oui il y a pas de discussion on passe
des journées des soirées à examiner des
textes budgétaires à voter on a
l'impression de faire du surplace et du
vélo d'appartement quoi vous pédalez et
puis vous avancez pas d'un centimètre
puisqu'à la sortie le gouvernement vous
dit tout ça ne sert à rien moi je vais
vous expliquer ce qui va se passer donc
on a l'impression que le gouvernement
n'a pas compris qu'il n'avait plus de
majorité à l'Assemblée nationale qu'il
fallait travailler avec l'ensemble des
forces politiques il ne le fait pas
c'est son droit d'utiliser le 49-3 ou
une fois qu'il le veut sur un texte
budgétaire uniquement c'est ce qu'il a
fait il va encore faire mais est-ce que
pour vous cela affaiblit la démocratie
vous l'avez dit à partir du moment où il
utilise une arme prévue par la
Constitution peut pas lui reprocher
d'utiliser cette arme pour autant
un gouvernement qui veut par la suite
essayer de trouver des solutions
majoritaires ça va rendre les choses
plus compliquées regardez les retraites
il va bien falloir parler on peut pas
mettre du 49-3 à toutes les sauces
politiquement c'est plus compliqué
techniquement vous l'avez dit surtout ce
qui est budgétaire 49-3 après il y en a
plus qu'un donc ce joker sur quel texte
vend-il l'utiliser et après il se passe
quoi et après il se passe quoi parce
qu'il va falloir trouver des majorités
donc si le gouvernement continue à
pratiquer le blocage comment va-t-il
pouvoir agir une fois qu'il n'aura plus
le 49-3 c'est la grande question en 2023
sur ce budget ce que le gouvernement va
quand même conserver certains apports du
Sénat dans cet examen du projet de loi
de finance est-ce que vous avez des
garanties notamment sur la pro des
protection des collectivités
territoriales non zéro garanti il était
prévu
il était prévu que le gouvernement
avance sur les propositions faites au
Sénat pour les collectivités
territoriales en particulier il devait
renoncer il s'était engagé à renoncer
à ce qu'on appelle le contrat de
confiance le 40 squatter en fait c'est à
dire les sanctions à l'égard des
collectivités qui étaient supposées
dépenses trop bon c'est une Miss sous
tutelle il y a plus de d'autonomie des
collectivités territoriales aujourd'hui
l'essentiel des recettes proviennent de
l'État et en plus on applique des
sanctions donc les collectivités sont
corsetés regardez la CVAE le
gouvernement a le choix entre aider les
collectivités ou aider les entreprises
une fois de plus on aide beaucoup les
entreprises et donc là ils font le choix
d'aider les entreprises en disant c'est
un impôt de production on le supprime il
va rester quoi aux collectivités et si
jamais le gouvernement ne retient aucune
des modifications du Sénat est-ce que
vous êtes favorable finalement en
deuxième lecture à un rejet du texte
sans examen bien sûr c'est ce qui va se
passer c'est ce qui va se passer on va
pas perdre encore une semaine à discuter
d'un texte ou à la sortie le
gouvernement va dire écoutez dites-nous
de quoi vous avez besoin on dira comment
vous en passer finalement tout ça ne va
servir à rien donc on va gagner du temps
une question peut-être un peu plus
politique Hervé Marseille la majorité au
Sénat est composé des LR de vous
centriste mais dans ce débat budgétaire
il semble que vous ayez pris un peu vos
distances avec vos collègues LR
notamment pour rejeter la suppression de
la CVAE cette impôt sur les entreprises
percées perçue par les les collectivités
ou pour défendre l'idée d'une taxe sur
les super profits est-ce que les
différences se creusent avec la majorité
ce que vous prenez un peu large par
rapport aux idées de vos collègues
galères on peut aussi dire ce qui eux
s'écarte de nos idées parce qu'il y a
pas une référence qui serait les choix
de LR et nous qui devrions voter non il
y a une majorité
il y a des compromis qui sont discutés
on le fait de façon très naturelle sous
l'autorité de Gérard Larcher mais il y a
aussi des différences et quand il y a
des différences on les assume même si
elles sont nettes comme c'est le cas par
exemple dans
les républicains sont de droite et
d'ailleurs ils passent leur journée à
cultiver
de quel droit ils vont se
dentir une fois passé leur congrès donc
c'est normal qu'il y ait des différences
puisque nous on est au centre donc quand
on a des positions et que elles ne sont
pas les mêmes on les assume je veux dire
sur la CVE l'idée c'était de dire on
refuse la suppression de la CVAE et à la
dernière minute nos collègues
républicains ont préféré faire un choix
différent au perçu par les collectivités
qui est un impôts de production qui pèse
sur les entreprises finalement ils ont
dit ah ben on va quand même peut-être
supprimer
et accepter la suppression de la moitié
de la CVAE et non c'est pas la ligne
qu'on avait défini ensemble donc on est
resté sur l'idée de défendre les
collectivités donc vous sentez que ce
dialogue avec les républicains se passe
moins bien depuis des mois alors qu'ils
sont en campagne pour la présidence DLR
et que la droite se durcit
non ça se passe bien globalement
simplement à partir du moment où il y a
une campagne interne chez les
républicains et j'allais dire dans tous
les partis parce que les socialistes les
communistes les Verts même le RN c'est
passé mais il y avait également des
élections internes
forcément les débats occasionnent des
grilles de lecture qui impactent les
textes et chez nos amis républicains bon
bah il y a une compétition entre
différents candidats quelque part ça
impacte forcément la lecture des textes
alors cette semaine avait Marcel
l'Assemblée nationale a donné le coup
d'envoi du débat sur les énergies
renouvelables un projet de loi destiné à
combler le retard français par un
développement massif de panneaux
solaires et d'éoliennes c'est l'un des
points de crispation du débat on va voir
ce compte rendu de séance fait par Elsa
le mot ne figure même plus dans le
projet de loi mais ce sont bien les
éoliennes qui ont cristallisé les débats
à droite et à l'extrême droite on
aimerait soit instaurer un droit de veto
pour les mers soit imposer un moratoire
il faut que nos compatriotes soient au
courant de ce que de ce qui se joue avec
ce texte c'est le déploiement d'éolienne
sur l'équivalent de 1% du territoire
national 1% du territoire national nous
on est là pourquoi on est là pour être
le dernier rempart renverse ceux qui ne
veulent pas se laisser faire envers ceux
qui veulent défendre ce qu'on a le plus
clair au monde nos paysages notre
patrimoine notre France la ministre de
la transition énergétique ne peut donc
que constater l'hostilité des
républicains et du rassemblement
national contre son projet de loi c'est
un refus de développer les énergies
renouvelables c'est un refus mais
assumez-le c'est pas un problème assumer
que vous ne voulez pas d'indépendance
énergétique de notre pays assumer que
vous ne voulez pas développer de
l'électricité pas carbone assumer que
vous préférez laisser les Français dans
le noir demain plutôt que de sortir des
énergies fossiles c'est donc vers la
partie gauche de l'hémicycle que le
gouvernement compte se tourner pour
obtenir une majorité mais il faut encore
convaincre avec vous sur ce texte nous
avons trouvé un dialogue véritable
exigeant parfois compliqué mais
constructif et qui a nous le pensons
permis à chacun d'évoluer sur ce texte
avec des plus et des moins nous restons
très attentifs au débat nous ne sommes
pas à l'abri de mauvaise surprise ou de
bonnes surprises pendant les temps de
nos débats les députés ont encore une
semaine pour examiner ce texte sur
lequel le gouvernement a exclu la
possibilité de recourir à l'article 49-3
Hervé Marseille alors ce droit de veto
souhaité par LR et par le rassemblement
national les députés qu'on a entendu
dans l'hémicycle est-ce que pour vous
c'est une bonne idée ce droit de veto
des mers sur les projets futurs
d'éoliennes non c'est pas une bonne idée
d'ailleurs nous l'avons dit je comprends
c'est tout à fait respectable mais c'est
plus une posture que une possibilité
pour les mères ça les met en difficulté
en responsabilité nous nous avons
préféré c'est ce qui a été retenu au
Sénat passer par les documents
d'urbanisme par une planification
territoriale où les mers sont impliquées
ou les élus sont impliqués mais où on
fait des zonages on dit là c'est
possible là c'est pas possible parce que
laisser un maire seul face à des
entreprises et lui laisser la seule
responsabilité ainsi que à ceux qui sont
entre en covisibilité sur un territoire
c'est les exposés à une responsabilité
très forte et donc
nous nous avons préféré ce choix c'est
ce qui a été retenu au Sénat et
justement lors de l'examen de ce texte
au Sénat à la base une partie des
sénateurs de la républicains étaient
favorable à ce droit de veto des mers
sur l'implantation d'éolienne et
finalement ce droit de veto a été
abandonné sous la pression des sénateurs
centrises est-ce que les républicains
ont encore été dans une posture
politiqueienne sur l'énergie
renouvelable dans ce débat écoutez moi
je crois que que c'était une une idée
sincère de leur part bon je n'ignore pas
au même moment il y avait le Congrès des
maires qui se réunissait je n'y vois pas
de coïncidence mais je pense qu'il y
avait peut-être un lien de cause à effet
je pense qu'on peut aider et défendre
les élus en ayant des idées plus
subtiles et et en tous les cas plus
efficace passer par la planification
territoriale c'est ce qui a été retenu
c'est une bonne chose maintenant on va
voir ce qui va rester à l'Assemblée
nationale ce que j'entends aujourd'hui
est un peu préoccupant
j'ai vu qu'il y avait un certain nombre
de modification qui avait été apporté au
texte quelque chose me dit que on a
intérêt à agir vite fait pour retrouver
de l'énergie et carbonée d'origine
nucléaire parce que qu'est-ce qui vous
préoccupe qu'est-ce qui vous préoccupe
sur les apports à l'Assemblée
les apports qui ont été faits
concernant notamment
les aspects visuels sur les sur les
territoires qui sont pas vraiment très
juridiques qui donnent des notions
extrêmement floues qui vont laisser la
main au juge et donc construire des
éoliennes ça va pas être une chose
facile alors justement plus globalement
Hervé Marseille est-ce que vous faites
confiance à ce projet de loi et aux
éoliennes pour accélérer la production
d'énergie bas carbone mais en France non
parce que de toute façon ça va être très
compliqué de construire il va falloir
prendre beaucoup de précautions les
précautions sont normales on peut pas
polluer comme on l'a vu les pays l'image
les bords de mer quand on voit ce qui
s'est passé à La Baule en particulier
ou visiblement il y a eu des
constructions un peu sauvages qui ont
été faites et sans tenir compte des élus
on peut effectivement s'inquiéter donc
je crois surtout dans l'énergie
nucléaire et il faut à tout prix qu'on
peut d'éolienne mais c'est vraiment pas
il faudra pas compter sur ça pour un
projet
donc ça va être compliqué c'est pas
demain que on va tout de suite pouvoir
avoir beaucoup d'énergie
renouvelables il s'est souhaitable mais
ça va prendre du temps question
politique Hervé Marseille vous succédez
à Jean-Christophe Lagarde à la
présidence de l'UDI l'UDA compte six
députés une trentaine de sénateurs
quelle est la ligne politique est-ce que
vous êtes dans une alliance avec le
gouvernement ou dans l'opposition nous
sommes dans l'opposition mais nous
sommes indépendants je veux dire
aujourd'hui
nous sommes responsables parce que comme
d'autres nous votons les textes quand il
nous paraissent de voir et de voter
parce qu'il y a des attentes pour le
pays des attentes pour la population qui
est en difficulté on voit bien les
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat les
problèmes énergétiques dont nous venons
de parler les problèmes sociaux parce
que il y a beaucoup dans les budgets
d'absence par exemple sur le logement
sur la dépendance
beaucoup d'angle morts donc nous nous
citons dans une position responsable
mais en même temps indépendante
c'est-à-dire que il y a pas de
systématisme et vous parliez des votes
au Sénat il y a une majorité sénatoriale
mais il y a aussi une indépendance de
notre part et nous assumons cette
indépendance est-ce que justement
l'alliance avec les LR à de l'avenir et
à quelles conditions
là aussi vous pouvez retourner la
question est-ce que les LR ont envie
d'avoir des partenaires
je les verrai je les entendrai surtout
une fois que nous connaîtrons la ligne
politique qui aura été définie par la
nouvelle direction des républicains
aujourd'hui des républicains
essaient de définir quel type de droite
va présider au mouvement est-ce que
c'est une droite
niçoise vendéenne
voilà moi je sais pas si c'est une
droite qui se referme sur elle-même qui
regarde sur sa droite ou qui a des
partenaires et comment ça se passe en
2023 à l'Assemblée nationale pour
trouver des majorités j'attends de
connaître un certain nombre de réponses
et d'orientation pour pouvoir y répondre
et pouvoir nous positionner alors votre
prédécesseur à la tête de l'UDI l'ancien
député Jean-Christophe Lagarde a été
condamné à 10 mois de prison avec sursis
pour avoir offert un affectif
d'assistante parlementaires à sa
belle-mère cette affaire avait Marseille
elle nuit à l'image de la politique
écoutez malheureusement eu pas mal de
d'affaires de ce type qui correspondait
à une certaine époque bon
Jean-Christophe est un ami donc je lui
garde mon amitié je déplore évidemment
toutes ces situations ça n'enlève pas
les liens d'amitié que j'ai pour lui
puis je lui souhaite le meilleur pour la
suite j'espère que il se tirera
d'affaires et qui sera faire justice de
tout ça voilà on va parler à
d'immigration Hervé Marseille puisque
mardi prochain une semaine après les
députés les sénateurs vont débattre de
la question migratoire et notamment du
projet loi immigration que le
gouvernement est en train de préparer un
texte qui prévoit d'accélérer les
procédures d'expulsion de régulariser
les travailleurs sans papier et de créer
un titre de séjour pour les métiers en
tension alors ce projet de loi pour
l'instant la droite sénatoriale est
contre on va écouter Bruno Retailleau le
président du groupe les républicains au
Sénat
la loi sur l'immigration c'est non
pourquoi
pour plein de raisons puisque il s'agit
pas de contrôler l'immigration massive
il s'agit au contraire d'ouvrir un peu
plus les vannes je vous démontre comment
François Hollande a déjà supprimé le
délit de ces jours illégal pour les
clandestins en 2012 et là en réalité on
va un peu plus loin c'est à dire que on
annonce que un clandestin arrivé sur le
sol français sera régularisé
automatiquement deuxième chose il y a un
deuxième guichet pour les déboutés du
droit d'Asie ils seront que si on les
refuse en termes de statut de réfugiés
ils auront droit à un second guichet qui
sera le guichet du travail non ça n'est
pas un projet de maîtrise de
l'émigration Hervé Marseille a priori
pour laisser un tort centrist la loi
immigration c'est oui
écoutez on va regarder ce qu'il était au
début de la discussion moi j'entends ce
que dit Bruno Retailleau qui d'emblée
refuse le texte moi j'ai une approche
beaucoup plus pragmatique c'est très
compliqué les affaires d'immigration
d'abord c'est un texte français alors
que une bonne partie des solutions se
trouve au niveau européen
il y a
l'immigrations européennes parce que une
fois que vous passez par l'Espagne ou
par l'Italie vous êtes en Europe et vous
allez partout donc on peut toujours
faire les malins chez nous en France
mais on connaît les limites des postures
et des coups de menton je veux dire on
sait très bien que c'est compliqué de
renvoyer les gens dans des pays
d'origine où les pays d'accueil ne
veulent plus les reprendre ce qui nous
met en difficulté notamment avec le
Maroc qui est un pays amis et on voit
bien que la difficulté on essaie de
faire pression en disant tant que vous
reprenez pas vos gens qui posent
problème en France nous on vous donne
plus de visa et il rigole et il passe
par l'Espagne qui elle donne les visas
et voilà donc il faut surtout trouver
des solutions européennes mais alors au
niveau du gouvernement alors le
gouvernement français a cette idée de
proposer un titre de séjour métier en
tension dans les secteurs qui peinent à
recruter pour vous c'est une bonne idée
pourquoi pas ça se discute ce sont les
patrons eux-mêmes qu'ils demandent et on
sait tous qu'il y a des métiers en
tension on sait tous qui a un tas de
gens qui travaillent dans des conditions
précaires sans papiers que ça soit dans
la restauration ou dans certaines
industries notamment touristiques et et
on fait semblant de ne pas regarder ce
qui se passe il y a une forme de logique
après il faut encadrer tout ça il faut
regarder comment ça peut marcher il faut
être pragmatique parce que si c'est
simplement pour dire écoutez on va
renvoyer les gens chez eux on laisse
plus passer personne et puis on peut pas
accepter les régularisations
écoutez on sait très bien que ça marche
pas on sait très bien que c'est pas la
réalité des choses je crois qu'il y a un
vrai débat européen qui doit être mené
puisque il y a un pacte d'immigration
qui était lancé en 2020 qui pour
l'instant patine entre temps il y a des
dispositifs de solidarité qui ont été
mis en place c'est compliqué on voit
bien avec nos amis italiens sont
toujours les mêmes qui accueillent
c'est-à-dire la France l'Italie
l'Espagne parce que c'est le sud et puis
on dit aux autres et ben on va partager
vous allez prendre oui mais pourquoi
croyez-vous que Madame Meloni a été élu
parce que les Italiens ils en ont un peu
un peu assez de d'accueillir toute la
misère du monde et à chaque fois on
inventait un truc formidable qui
s'appelle la dublinisation les accords
de Dublin c'est à dire que quand on
attrape quelqu'un sur le sol européen
par exemple à Calais on dit par où es-tu
arrivé il dit par Lampedusa on le
renvoie à Vintimille en lui disant bonne
chance tu verras c'est formidable Italie
donc ça peut pas marcher il faut trouver
des solutions collectives et moi je dis
il faut qu'on en parle on peut pas
rejeter un texte d'emblée je sais que
c'est compliqué et donc nous on va
examiner avec un avis plutôt favorable
ce texte mais est-ce que cette
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier ça ne va pas créer un appel d'air
migratoire en tout cas ce que dit la
droite et rassemblement national oui
mais moi je veux bien qu'on court à
droite toutes à chaque fois qu'on parle
de domaine régalien il y a quelqu'un qui
est formidable et qui réussit à tous les
coups dans ce domaine c'est Madame Le
Pen
s'il y en a une qui récupérera c'est
elle donc je crois que quand on dit
qu'on est des parties de gouvernement
qu'un jour on a vocation à retourner au
gouvernement de ce pays on essaie
d'avoir des attitudes et des
propositions qui soient réalistes et
dont on pourrait s'inspirer le jour où
on est en responsabilité si c'est pour
dire la même chose que Madame Le Pen ou
que monsieur Zemmour c'est pas la peine
de se fatiguer il y a déjà les recettes
donc là il a l'air court un petit peu
après Madame Le Pen sur l'immigration je
sais pas ce qu'ils font c'est à eux de
décider mais en tous les cas ils seront
jamais meilleurs que ces deux là alors
ce projet de loi qui va être présenté on
le dit en février au Sénat en mars à
l'Assemblée mais enfin il a déjà été
repoussé une fois est-ce que vous pensez
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout ou qui sera à
nouveau repoussé et surtout que le
gouvernement va finir par trouver une
majorité sur un sujet clivant et moi je
crois qu'en 2023 il y a deux grands
sujets qui vont être au cœur de la
réflexion de la politique pour toutes
les formations politiques républicaines
c'est d'abord comment on fait
fonctionner le Parlement puisqu'il n'y a
pas de majorité et qu'il n'y aura plus
de 49,3 il y en aura un seul bon une
fois passé les retraites si
il est confirmé que elles sont discutées
en partie au mois de janvier c'est à
dire sur la mesure d'âge bon c'est du
domaine budgétaire et ça sera un budget
rectificatif donc on peut utiliser le
carton
on doit avoir madame borne cette semaine
mais c'est ce qui était annoncé bon
après il restera 1 49-3 je sais pas ce
que le gouvernement décidera de faire
avec son 49,3
ça peut être pour un autre dossier que
ce soit l'immigration ou le travail ou
je ne sais quoi d'autre ce sera un choix
gouvernemental bon mais après il va bien
falloir que le pays
avance que le Parlement travaille qui
dit des textes qui répondent aux
préoccupations des Françaises et des
Français donc
c'est la première grande question et la
deuxième grande question c'est comment
on s'organise politiquement pour éviter
que Madame Le Pen devienne présidente de
la République en 2027 et donc pour vous
faut renforcer une alliance autour
d'Emmanuel Macron pour éviter ça
j'ai pas la recette j'ai posé la
question je pense que c'est compliqué
sinon ça serait mais enfin ce sont les
questions me semble-t-il que les
responsables politiques devront se poser
en 2023 vous parlez de la réforme des
retraites pour finir si jamais le
gouvernement sur cette réforme aux 49.3
est-ce que ce serait acceptable est-ce
qu'il faut faudrait encourager à le
censurer
nous avons la conviction que il faut
réformer d'ailleurs nous avons voté un
texte depuis plusieurs années au Sénat
qui est un texte équilibré mesure d'âge
64 ans
accélération de ce qu'on appelle le
Touran c'est-à-dire les durées de
cotisation et puis un travail sur la
pénibilité les carrières longue durée
c'est un peu ce qu'il faudrait trouver à
l'arrivée et je pense que le
gouvernement pourrait s'en inspirer
parce que ça va être une réforme
difficile on voit bien que les syndicats
et les Français d'ailleurs sont ceux qui
sont prêts à la réforme alors que on est
quand même c'est difficile de faire le
bonheur des gens malgré eux et donc il
va falloir beaucoup de discussions je
pense qu'il y a des pistes en
particulier on est dans un pays où tout
le monde veut garder la retraite à 60
ans la retraite le les 35 heures et puis
la santé gratuite après on s'étonne
d'avoir beaucoup d'impôts bon par
exemple si on veut pas que l'âge de la
pas trop long il faut peut-être toucher
aussi aux 35 heures il faut peut-être
travailler plus pendant la semaine Hervé
Marseille on va finir rapidement par un
petit coup d'oeil à l'agenda de
l'Assemblée nationale la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
le moment fort à l'Assemblée nationale
ce sera la lecture définitive du budget
on en parlait Hervé Marseille ce sera
jeudi 15 décembre faute d'accord le
gouvernement devrait utiliser une ultime
fois l'article 49-3 de la Constitution
faire passer le budget et c'est la fin
de cette émission merci beaucoup Hervé
Marseille d'y avoir participé et merci à
tous de l'avoir suivi
[Musique]